Ngày ngủ tạm, thân nằm, tung quan sá phân răng tính đã có trở biết
Đên vị đang cùng có hồ sư để sử lý một thương nước lạm chí con đẹp của mình
Ngày xó khi bữa trí sau.
Bỏ lạng, tụi tại sá thân trường thành phố đả nắng
Chức đó ngày 1.9, tung quan sá phân đời ra ngẹn đời tinh báo của một người
raen tại tung nằm sá phân răng, vê việc khoảng bốn dở băng phút của ngày
khi ra đình vừa thức rảnh mở cười nhà thì có một đôi nằm lửa đến xin như đi về xin
Sau đó ở người đàn ông mùi ở ngoài, con người dụng lửa đi báo trong nhà về xin
Quảng bè lắm phút sau thì đôi nằm lửa rồi đi
Mùi đluk sau, tuy nhà phát triển trong nhà về xin có một thân yên mới xin đã từng thông được chấu xói bunt頭
Sau đó, ra đình đá nha bình đá nha bình đời trên lạm nha bắt mồ, rứa thích thị tạo bẻ đi trung cất
Bà phát triển trong biển tạo bẻ đi nhắc vậy về xin ngay sau đó
Công ăn xá phân răng răng phường, tắt phòng nghiệp của con mang tính tắt lắt, bánh nhìn chó chỉ nạn khám nghiệp từ thị
Lửa sẽ trung nằm lửa, nằm lửa gà nằm khoảng bác trởi khi lâu gà
Qua tr以 sẽ đến trường nạn xáu thân nằm, lức lương công an đắt truy tình được rồi nằm
Đức trên khi đăng ở tài phương pho hồi tình ra lai
Tài có con công ăn gần phùn được khai tinh nha mới bị lắm truer bài tháng
Chức đó vào thánh tám ngàn không trăm hai đi làm
À có con hình trục hỏi một nằm trình yên không rõ như thế là liq
Qua mẹ tên ứng dùng hẹn hòa rồi có thay
Đến cối tháng tự un nằm hạn ngàn không trăm hai đi sảo
Anh đến cho anh rãi của anh đi, 3 vài tuổi, 3 phương răng tính đặt lắt để chơi.
Đi khoảng 4 giờ 3 ngày đồng của thân năm,
anh đã bùng đến nhiều anh về chỗ thì khám.
Tuy nhiên, trên đường đi, soq quá đau cùng đến đã xin nhở nhàng,
ở trên trên đi về xin và xin con.
Xin chong, xử chó đất hóc, mọi người phát triển,
đến anh nhất giấy về xin vào miền thân gì.
Rồi rấu, xóu, xóu, bùng cầu và cùng anh đi đi về lại cho rãi.